il ya six mois stéphane besle il
travaillait chez un manufacturier
d'uniformes loin des hôpitaux
je me retrouve dans l'uniforme
changement carrière total la vie de jean
charles statnett tournait autour de son
restaurant
une fois que la pandémie est arrivé
méchant du conquet fallait changer et
c'est tellement depuis plus de deux ans
les fils de joël et michel leroy prenait
des nouvelles de leur mère le plus
souvent possible à partir de boston ou
new york
malvy progresser masser doucement en
arrivant ici on a pu vraiment voir
l'évolution h en direct en mars
pas question pour stéphane délisle de
ruminer longtemps sur la fermeture
abrupte de l'entreprise pour laquelle
ils travaillaient au marketing depuis
plus de vingt ans c'était dans le maine
facturation de vêtements établir des
relations d'affaires avec différentes
corps de police ou en blanc c'est aux
autres aussi tout on lui offre un
travail d'agent de sécurité à l'hôpital
général juif de montréal
j'avais pas de permis d'agent j'ai été
chercher mon permis d'agent temporaire
en l'espace de deux mois
monsieur b lille a pris du galon donc je
me retrouve comme supérieur à gérer a
coaché si on veut des agents et de l'onm
à faire un post pour scène les cinq
prochaines années le hasard y est
peut-être pour quelque chose mais sa
passion pour le taekwondo aussi comme
entraîneur il a organisé des
compétitions d'envergure
on a une maîtrise de soi même on est un
contrôle de nos émotions
on est capable aussi de juger le danger
début de la livrer 20 ou magie n'est pas
un changement de carrière pas du tout
pas du tout je pense que c'est ça m'est
arrivé de belle façon
je suis vraiment vraiment
c'était ma maison et puis
le virus est arrivé donc on nous a
imposé à fermer là c'était très dur avec
le déconfinement il a rouvert son
restaurant fin juin les vielles de le
fermer définitivement
ça faisait neuf ans que j'étais en
activité
et puis avec la période de pandémie et
difficulté m'ont fait réfléchir j'ai
décidé d'arrêter parce que je pouvais
pas continuer financièrement
une voix s'est alors imposée j'ai des
bases en gestion de restaurants et en
cuisine chez autodidacte en fait il
reviendra à sa passion en passant par
l'école une formation professionnelle en
pâtisserie qui commence en octobre
j'ai 48 ans g20 en expérience quand vous
voulez postuler en des endroits on vous
prend pas parce que j'ai pas de diplôme
un virage qui lui permet aussi de faire
ce qu'ils ne pouvaient pas faire honte
oui j'ai profité à que ce changement de
visiter les régions du québec
la pandémie ne changera pas le cours de
la maladie de joël leroy la sclérose
latérale amyotrophique dont elle souffre
depuis plus de deux ans mais le
confinement à transformer sa faim de
vienne
non c'est un cadeau pour joël de m'avoir
à la maison et ainsi que les enfants
maintenant je suis en télétravail
appelons à temps à temps plein grâce aux
coville 19 po comme ça va bien arrangé
de pouvoir rester ici parce que je ne
pouvais pas rester seul l'aîné de la
famille travail aux etats-unis et le
cadet il fait un doctorat
je pensais que ça allait de quelques
semaines on parlait à des trois quatre
semaines atteint 2 mois on retourne à
l'école et finalement les respecter un
peu plus longtemps
arni le roi est retourné quelques
semaines dans les laboratoires du hem
haïti à boston savent bien tombe au bon
moment
à partir de maintenant je pense que je
pourrais presque presque fini à distance
autre cadeau pour joël leroy la présence
de sa soeur elle a pu enfin venir de
belgique et peut prolonger son séjour
grâce au télétravail
c'est un cadeau pour toute la famille
pas juste m même si c'est pour nous
passer des bons moments ensemble
[Musique]
donc les proches de nous nous y avoir
plus difficile à comprendre sa mère
s'est pas toujours face et les mots - on
est chanceux d'être cyr
la toute situation il ya des bons
devrait il est bon
[Musique]
proche oui elle
ça n'arrive pas pour rien non
[Musique]
et
pour profiter valise et quelques
importants